take a walk ders I don't want to have to
kick your ass okay Adam this is so dumb
all right I'd like to get to this photo
shoot on time try being a pacifist I'll
be a pacifist I'll pass my fist through
your face that's not possible oh isn't
it I'm suing I'm serious is this
possible
drop 30 spots in the rankings because of
you yeah claw degraaf's gon feel like I
threw away my whole early 20s for
nothing sucks for you but it's not about
you it's about me in this job I know
Adam you're not fighting ters fighting
me link Adam who got nobody out Adam
over you all right about you waiting on
ders not even fight I still want to get
bits off this off you want me you got me
dude yourself good luck
oh thanks man
[Music]
taking me even a blind man can add a
punch if he sees it in his mind's eye
first
[Music]
your fault